a lot of people are starting to talk
about Ai
and you I mean people will say you're a
political commentator but I think of you
more as a philosopher to a large extent
you think about society and and the ways
that it's changing and where it's going
do you have thoughts on what AI May mean
for Humanity
not many I mean I as you say I sort of
straddle both of those divides
um
that you just described I uh I've looked
into a certain amount I do think that
it's obviously running the the treadmill
is running faster than humans can run
and that's that's the problem the recent
letter signed by Elon and others uh uh
was a sign of that the one I'm worried
about frankly is
um
I'm worried about what happens if
America does put a pause on on this
because America might put a pause on it
you know Britain might put a pause on it
but other countries won't
I think there's a risk that it'll become
like stem cells you know like America
ends up like stopping certain research
here for for profound and you
you know important moral reasons
but go to Central America and that's
happening all over the place
so my worry with the AI one is that
America and advanced democracies say
whoa
but you know China doesn't
um that that seems to me to be the worst
of all worlds is that the technology is
developed by by countries that are
already
um
not free to say the least
but I don't know what to do about that
um
I don't know what the answer to that is
other than continuing carefully to do it
in our own societies
um but in the end you know you can't
you can't actually hold back learning it
is the truth of it you know
um
I mean
it's it's like Guttenberg once it's out
you just can't hold it back you can't
stop the printing presses once they
start rolling
um you can't start the internet once
it's turned on
um
and again it's probably always been like
this you know they probably felt the
same when gunpowder was first discovered
um
futility to to thinking about these
things
well not a futility because it's very
interesting but I think I think people
are misguided if they think that
that thinking about things like Ai and
being able to control them are the same
thing
um
I mean as I say I mean you can think
about gunpowder
but it doesn't win you any battles
um you can think about this discovery of
the Canon or the invention the the
automatic rifle
doesn't win you any battle
um we could think endlessly about the
nature of AI but I I think the
likelihood that you'll be able to stop
it is is is highly unlikely I think the
one thing that
I think the one thing that does worry me
about it and it's something which um
you know various philosophers have
talked about in recent decades is you
know there is there is a sort of moment
when
I mean arguably you could trace the
moment that we're currently in back to
that moment in what was it 1994 when
Gary Kasparov played the computer at
chess and lost
and the notes that uh Kasparov was um
uh making as he went along there was
there was a very striking note one of
his notes himself was he said the
machine isn't calculating its thinking
that's a very important moment in the
development of what we now call AI
um there's another observation on that
which um
which Tom stoppard wrote in his play the
hard problem about the Consciousness
problem so interesting profound play he
mentions that the only time that he says
that were one of the characters that's
in the play something I've always been
fond of which is um that the
that the machines only really beat the
humans when the machine's mind losing
um because minding losing is such a huge
human Drive
uh wanting to win wanting to you know
come back
um
I think at this point the machines do
mind losing or very close to it
the one that
alarms me more is the issue of memory
and human memory because human memory
and machine memory are clearly different
things I mean I know this from our own
life spans already as a sort of weird uh
Gap from before the internet era it was
recently actually shown when Jerry Adams
of shinfoen Ira was back in the news and
somebody mentioned that on me Wikipedia
website for Jerry Adams the only
controversy under controversies is
um when he used the N word some years
ago in passing and got a lot of flack
for it I mean it's an explosive issue
it's well said but but he's been
involved in more explosive issues in his
time
and you would have thought that and Mr
Adams can sue me if he thinks I'm wrong
on this but
you would have thought that a man who
was high up in an organization which
he's always denied being a member of and
an organization that killed 1600 people
and disappeared mothers and buried their
bodies after torturing and shooting them
in the back of her head
should be on Wikipedia as a potential
controversy
my point is
not to get onto that hobby horse's mind
but my point is is that there is this
sort of Knowledge from before the
internet era which the internet is not
capable of holding
it's the same with the television
archives
um there are things that like exist on
YouTube only because they exist on
YouTube and somebody's posted them but
there's all of this forgotten memory of
of what was before will the machines
ever be able to do the the things that
we have up here
maybe someday
but it'll be different from Human memory
um I don't relish the world in which the
machine can compete
with the greatest human mind
um because to my mind one of the things
that makes humans humans is
is having a sense of memory
um
Collective familial
and much more
and it also brings for the discussion
about AI art because I was talking with
Andrew Doyle about this and he said well
hey I can't create art because art is
the expression of the human soul but you
see everything that has been created
over it with AI and it's already so
Advanced that you think to yourself is
it going to make the artist obsolete
um I don't think that will happen
actually I mean certainly what we what
what has been produced so far doesn't
fool me at any rate
um uh it's it's a currently AI Artist as
far as I can see it are purely parasitic
art form it can only work off what's
already there so it can imitate and it
can imitate pretty well
um
it actually is quite easy to spot I
would say at the moment some people
watching will disagree and will download
send in examples that I couldn't spot uh
I still think that if someone if AI
faked to Vermeer I would be able to tell
um I'd be able to tell the difference
between the fake and the real
um maybe partly because there were so
few vermeers that I would know but
um
certain artists might be easier to fake
than others
it's not hard to figure Warhol because
it wasn't hard to make
um uh but will they be able to make
advances in perception
of the kind that say in the 20th century
Picasso and Francis Bacon imagine will
they be able to push forward the the
boundaries like that I
I doubt it I think it'll be like in
music I mean
in in music almost everything in film
music for instance is already imitative
parasitic art AI can create more of it
but can AI create Stravinsky I doubt it
I doubt it
foreign